もうなぁ一弦一番に向いてるあの
チャンネル登録者数700万人ありがとうございます実感がありません僕今住んでる
この静岡県の人口をかけるんにそんな人数の人が登録されていると思うと
ちょっともよくわかんないですよね特に8日はないで今までどおり顔を合わせて頂き
ますよろしくお願いします
ですなぜあのちょっと体調の話になるんですけど実は僕あの辺りつもっちで有名でして
結構定期的に頭が痛くなったりするんですよてくるタイミングがもう分かっててなんか
定期奴が来る前日駅奴が来る
なんか20時間前くらいに保護必ずっていうぐらい頭が痛くなります台風が来る前日と
かめっちゃ体調悪くてガードが休んだりねこんなにするんですけども今回何度ですね
その辺ずつに匹敵するような痛みがもう
5日間も続いておりますえっ
八つ伊予孔玉ガンガンガンガンしますからねこの後頭部の心根ここらへんがもんだが
血管が圧迫されてもう物議れる寸前みたいな感覚に陥っておりますあの素直にまずは
今年で一番つらいですで何かね分かんなかったんですよな2時はすごい変絶縁の頭痛に
逃げたんねあーなんかこれた部品図2なんだろうなと思ってたら寝て
治るかなと思ったんですけどまっ嫡男なくてむしろ悪化してうわーこれちょっとが
なかなか今回返事ツヤばいいなと思って僕らの睡眠不足なんですよね世民べえ速だから
なんか寝たらなるかなと思って実はあのちゃんと寝ようと思って10時間くらいバーっ
と寝たんですけど寝て起きたら悪化してました
voodoo はこれぞんだこれやバーと
持ってあのロキソニンで区にあるじゃないですか頭痛に効くやつそれで一番釣れず
ロキソニン s プレミアなぁこういう頭痛薬があるんですけど全部んじゃった63に
ももう全部載っちゃったんですけどあの効果なしっ痛みが和らぐ所が何の変化もない
です逓増もう5日も続いてですで会長は元気なんですよ生チャーハンが明治に出るか
ないか
あとなが頭が痛すぎてはっきりがする東京仙台とか言ってるちょっと病院に行く暇が
なくて
体は元気本当に頭だけが考えたいから意外とパイれるんですよね
やっぱり脳みそって結構ヤバいんですよ頭痛ってなんかその口をまっか出血だったら
本当に危ないし
まぁちょっとパソボンドがめっちゃ似てるからなんか頭よやられてもう俺やべんかなと
思ってあのさすがに今回はちょっと
逆に年ぶりぐらいかの病院に行きがせていただきます
強いでしたら病院行きたくないですってくそ元気なんですよ
元気だからほんと頭が痛いだけでちょっと治んないなぁと思ってちょっと病院に行かせ
ていただきます
でなんかに清水としてはをとりあえず上手痛いんですよずっといたいしたか寝て起きた
時もかなり痛いで浮いてるとなく肩凝ってるわけでもない多分会なんかでしたがいたり
すると何かめっちゃくちゃズキズキズキズキ結果も物議なるくらい痛くて打った
たりすると痛いですね何だろうなんかた作るみたいな感じなんかな立ったりちょっと
激しい運動したりするとめっちゃここらへんが猛牙機に痛くなります
あのぜひみなさんにも体験してもらいたいぐらいあの頭が勝つはれる痛み結構しんどい
やつでなんかもいろいろ考えられだけが vita 3ds ですって話でもちょっと
8日がないんでとりあえず病院で何が原因かを調べていきま
頭痛で悩んでる人とかいるかも分からないんだよ一応参考までに動画にしておきます
うん行ってきます第スコール病院たとこ見たことある
ここを2年ぐらいでペンミドリン
もねと陸すんのこれぐらいの
久しぶりの病院です結構ほんといつかかんとか笑えないんでちょっと病院でちゃんと見
てもらっています
いてよくやっ
[音楽]
[拍手]
マリオパーティ買ったった
も出ている多分
行ってきます
[音楽]
[拍手]
入っていきます
[音楽]
いかんどっ
ています
はい帰ってきました先にこの5日間も続く頭痛の原因から発表します
頭痛の原因はん
ん
パナリ村
花です
花はなですはちょっとまだの多い者さんと話したところそれが本当の原因かどうかをし
たまた末端ないんでとレジストのオックス下もらってきたんですけどもみなさん蓄膿症
ってわかりますか
複利ぺーンと思うんですけども地区の招福ビック園による頭痛の可能性が高いという
ことです
まあいろいろオックスでもらってきたんですけどもうバッテリー
21000一番良かった長さの中すごいでかい
なんかその深刻な頭痛っていうのがヤバい病気とかの可能性もあったんですけどそう
いうのじゃなくて釣れず安心しましたかといってもこの舌もまずひどすぎるし5日間も
続いて本当にヤバイんでなんでこんなことが起きてるかっていうちょっと説明だけさせ
てください蓄膿症その花とかねこれに
膿が溜まってカード頃に変な臭いがすると炎症があるんですけども
だからそのそれが原因で頭痛につながってるという可能性が今のところ高いみたいです
でもらった薬もなんだこれ案とか海を薄めて出すおっ薬と縫製物質でその細菌による
感染症を治療する薬の2つをもらいましたてがなぜ健康な未婚なりたいからゲー
人がわからなすぎてほんと怖かった抗菌剤を服用して海を直せばもう普通にが居る
らしいですいざにノー真剣師科クリニックっていうあのクリニックのサイトがあるん
ですけどもそちらを見るとかなり分かりやすいかと思います俺がさっき言ってた少女と
めっちゃ被ってるのかですよねこの普及服園による頭痛の特徴は以下の通りですという
文章があります
頭痛の始まった時期に一致して鼻水鼻づまりがある
しばし北人数でるんでもう一個起床時に一番痛みが強い
はい行くまい病院くらいに言いましたよねメリットキーにすごい頭が痛いって言いまし
たはいねえど頭を前屈する下を向くと痛みが悪化する
はいいう松井ました行くまいりましたねほっぺあー3型を叩くと痛む
はぁ
[音楽]
ん
ちょっとわかんないですねあと今までになく連日頭痛が続くはいもうこれが本当に
怖かったです
同じ症状出すっていうちょっとでなかなかでこれなかなか知らない人が多いらしくて
なんかめちゃくちゃヤバイ2思って病院に来る患者さんのなかで行こうこれが原因って
人が多いらしいですか寸とかが原因になるらしいぽいことも書いてあるんでけっこう
痛みがすぐ
来てづらい人が多いみたいですはいというわけで力に続くそう
舌な痛みは副鼻くう炎ここに膿がたまっているのが原因だったみたいでございます
いやをなんか
辛いー
me
バッハ